esta vez vamos a intentar encontrar las
soluciones para esta ecuación que tengo
aquí tenemos 2 x 3 esto elevado al
cuadrado es igual a 4 x menos 6 y te
invito a que pausa el vídeo y le eches
un vistazo intentando resolver por ti
mismo pero te voy a dar una pista
puedes hacerlo de la manera tradicional
es decir expandiendo esto que tengo aquí
y ponerlo en una forma cuadrática
tradicional y después usar la fórmula
general pero puede ser que haya una
forma más fácil o más simple de resolver
este ejercicio si realmente pones
atención en la estructura de ambos lados
de esta ecuación puede ser que
encuentres un camino más rápido
ok vamos a ver esto en el lado izquierdo
tenemos 2 x 3 esto elevado al cuadrado y
bueno del lado derecho tengo 4 x 6 pero
si observas el lado derecho puedes ver
que esta parte de aquí es lo mismo que
dos veces 2 x menos 3
es decir que si de esta parte factor y
son 2 me va a quedar 2 que multiplica a
2 x menos tres es más vamos a hacerlo
por aquí quiero ser muy claro con esto
en el lado izquierdo me va a quedar 2 x
menos 3 esto elevado al cuadrado y del
lado derecho me va a quedar 2 2 voy a
factorizar un 2 que multiplica a su vez
a 2 x menos es muy bien y es que esto es
muy interesante porque tenemos algo
elevado al cuadrado que es igual a 2
veces ese mismo algo es decir que la
cosa está que voy a poner de color azul
en esta cosa que tengo de color azul al
cuadrado es igual a 2 veces esa misma
cosa de color azul
entonces si podemos resolver para esta
cosa de color azul luego podemos
resolver para x y te voy a mostrar como
para eso vamos a usar un poco de
sustitución y vamos a reemplazar con
penn a esta cosa que tenemos de color
azul dicho de otra manera voy a decir
que pepe
es igual a esto que tengo aquí adentro
de mi paréntesis
es menos 3 ese va a ser el valor de p y
ahora observan date cuenta que esta
ecuación se va a simplificar mucho si
hacemos este cambio de variable porque
nos va a quedar lo siguiente nos va a
quedar que p cuadrada que p déjame
ponerlo con este color p cuadrada va a
ser igual a dos veces p a dos veces p
porque recuerda que pep es 2x menos 3 y
ahora solamente tenemos que resolver
para p y bueno voy a cambiar de color y
voy a usar un único color pero observen
lo siguiente lo que podemos hacer es
bueno primero voy a pasar este 2 p del
otro lado de la ecuación dicho de otra
manera voy a restar 2 p de ambos lados
de la ecuación así que me va a quedar p
cuadrada menos dos veces p
esto es igual a 0 y en este momento se
te puede ocurrir que podemos sacar a p
como factor común
que multiplica ap-2 esto es igual a cero
lo hemos visto muchas veces recuerdas y
si tengo el producto de dos cosas son
iguales a cero entonces al menos una de
ellas debe de ser cero eso quiere decir
que en este caso
p es igual a cero open es igual a cero o
en su dado caso de menos dos esto va a
ser igual a cero ahora bien si p menos
12 es igual a cero eso quiere decir que
p tiene que ser igual a 2 estás de
acuerdo bueno pero todavía no terminamos
porque recuerda que queremos resolver
para x no para p pero por suerte sabemos
que es igual a 2 x 3 así que esto me va
a quedar de la siguiente manera podemos
decir que
2 x 3 es igual a 0 o 2 x menos 3 esto es
igual a cero o bueno en su dado caso 2 x
menos 3 es igual a 2
2x menos 3 es igual a 2 y esto bueno es
bastante sencillo de resolver porque en
este caso si sumamos 3 de ambos lados
que me va a quedar me va a quedar que 2x
es igual a 3 y si ahora dividimos todo
entre 2 todo entre 2 estos 2 se cancelan
y me va a quedar que x es igual a 3
medios o bueno si te das cuenta aquí
arriba también podemos obtener un valor
para x si sumamos de ambos lados 3 me va
a quedar que 2x es igual a 5 y si
dividimos todo entre 2 todo entre 2
estos dos se van a ir y me va a quedar
que x es igual a 5 medios estas dos son
mis posibles soluciones para la ecuación
con la que empecé y esto es bastante
claro porque si te fijas en esto que
tengo aquí puedes darte cuenta que es
muy sencillo hasta lo puedes hacer en tu
cabeza esto de aquí es bonito y simple
y bueno si hubiera expandido esto al
cuadrado y después sobre arrestado esta
parte de aquí al final estoy seguro que
llegarías a la respuesta correcta pero
hubieras hecho un conjunto de
operaciones mucho más complejo eso
quiere decir que te llevaría muchos más
pasos pero lo que estuvo muy bien es que
aquí pudimos apreciar algunos patrones
que vivimos en nuestra ecuación
concretamente nos dimos cuenta que
teníamos algo elevado al cuadrado igual
a 2 veces ese mismo algo y bueno esa
cosa eran 2 x 3